considera la curva cerrada en el plano
xy definida por la siguiente ecuación
encuentra las coordenadas de dos puntos
sobre la curva donde la recta tangente a
la curva es vertical pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolver esto por su cuenta en
este momento no conocemos cuál es la
forma real de esta curva pero vamos a
dibujar una curva cerrada cualquiera
esta curva también tiene dos puntos
donde la recta tangente a la curva es
vertical uno es este y el otro es este
como vamos a encontrarlos lo que podemos
hacer es hacer una derivación implícita
para encontrar la derivada de g con
respecto a x y pensar los valores de xy
que hacen que la derivada no tenga cero
en el numerador y sea cero en el
denominador vamos a hacer lo
reescribimos la ecuación vamos a
calcular la derivada con respecto a x a
ambos lados de la ecuación queremos
encontrar una expresión de ye con
respecto a x esto es 2 x + 2 + 4 al cubo
por la derivada de con respecto a x pues
aplicamos la regla de la cadena
la derivada de esto con respecto a jane
es 4 por la derivada de ye con respecto
a x ya que aplicamos de nuevo la regla
de la cadena esto es igual a la derivada
de una constante con respecto a x que es
cero ahora despejamos deje de x tomamos
2 x + 2 y lo arrestamos a ambos lados de
la ecuación también podemos factorizar
el 4 de x de aquí si hacemos todo esto
nos queda 4x porque al cubo más 1 que es
igual a menos 2 por x 1
recuerden que restamos 2x + 2 a ambos
lados ahora solo tenemos que dividir
todo entre 4 x esto de acá nos queda la
derivada de ya con respecto a x es igual
a menos 2 por x 1 entre 4 porque al cubo
más 1 simplificamos esto nos queda menos
x más 1 / 2 x al cubo más uno
simplemente dividimos numerador y
denominador entre 2 para qué nos sirve
esto pues con esto podemos encontrar más
fácilmente los valores de iu que hacen
que el denominador sea 0 y también nos
permite encontrar
aquellos valores de x que hacen que el
numerador sea diferente de 0 esto es
igual a 0 cuando es igual a menos 1 y
para igual a menos 1 qué valores podemos
tener para x sustituimos por menos 1 en
la ecuación original y despejamos x
vamos a hacerlo y vamos a hacer un poco
de espacio que necesitamos para esto si
sustituimos por menos 1 nos queda x
cuadrada más 2 x + 1 - 4 igual a 5 esto
es menos tres préstamos 5 a ambos lados
y nos queda x cuadrada más 2 x menos 8
igual a cero factor izamos y nos queda x
+ 4 por x 2 estos valores los
encontramos porque son los dos números
que al multiplicarse dan menos 8 y al
sumar se dan 2
finalmente x es igual a menos 4 o es
igual a 2 cuando ya es igual a menos 1
para responder a la pregunta del
enunciado decimos que son los puntos x
igual a menos 4 y igual a menos 1 y x
igualados ya igual a menos 1 con eso
terminamos y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo